Starting out with our function, f of x equals 2x minus 3 over 5. I've gone
through the same steps that you've become very familiar with during this
lesson. First, I switched from f of x to y to make a notation easier to handle.
Then, to switch to the inverse function, I interchanged x and y. So instead, we
have the function, x equals 2y minus 3 over 5. Then I went through a few stuffs
to solves for y. Getting y by itself on one side gave is the equation 5x plus 3
over 2 equals y. Then I just switched the two sides of the equation and changed
y to f inverse of x. That gives us a final equation of f inverse of x equals 5x
plus 3 over 2. Let's double check that this is the right answer. Remember, we
can do that by looking at the composition of f inverse and f and the
composition of f and f inverse. f of f inverse affects is 2 times the quantity
5x plus 3 over 2 minus 3, all over 5. Let's simplify this and sure enough, we
end up with x. Let's try the composition, the other way around. For f inverse
of f of x, we have 5 times the quantity 2x minus 3 over 5, plus 3 all over 2.
And sure enough, cleaning this up, we get x as well. We've now verified that f
inverse of x really is this expression. 5x plus 3 over 2. I hope at this point
you feel really comfortable finding the inverses of different functions. And
then checking that they actually are their inverses. Remember this also means
that not only is 5x plus 3 over 2 the inverse of 2x minus 3 over 5, but 2x
minus 3 over 5 is also the inverse of this function. They're inverses of one
another. It's a two-way relationship.